should we just get to this guy now yes
yeah let's just get in alright I bought
a little cake with cocoa to write a cake
but we're gonna bring this cake with
some [ __ ] swag with some [ __ ] swag
happy birthday to you happy birthday to
you
happy birthday
happy birthday
happy birthday
yeah
[Laughter]
there
straight up yeah
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
that sounds like it no blood the candle
die a happy girl out too can know what's
another g-major song a happy birthday to
the podcast first of all happy birthday
to all of you thank you all so much for
supporting us it's party time
yep
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
your blow this [ __ ] out
[Laughter]
yeah wait
yep beautiful lasered that I gotta turn
that down
I'll include this we should just podcast
like this for me yeah this is awesome
yeah yes we could break out in a song
yeah it's a musical podcast yeah you
just do Travis Scott do the same was not
the key yeah exactly the effect is the
explorers way yeah can
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
you guys probably turn this off now
we're gonna do this for 15 minutes I
mean I mean while we're doing it we
might as well do butterfly fix we might
as well just you might as well turn on
the the Louis shooters effect with a
major of it a console or live studio
engine engineer yeah this is what the
live shell is gonna sound laughs yeah
Jamie can we uh you have you seen that
[ __ ] deer there's even a [ __ ]
video that deer getting hit by that
[ __ ] car yo Jamie can you put that on
please
Joe Rogan's auto-tune for whatever
reason I got the blue shoes to children
again oh my god Jamie can we get the car
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
can we add a clip of that deer him
getting hit by a car
Conor what was going to your mind when
compressor for
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
what's up guys let's end it on B major
holy [ __ ] well I hope you all had as
much fun uh thank you so much no
seriously this [ __ ] for a year straight
should we say this on the regular Mike
what it is real quick
yeah thank you Spock thanks Bach thanks
mark for being our live yeah studio
engineer sick oh my god holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] my stomach oh yeah dude [ __ ] that
killed me um big thank you to Spock for
being here
he was far first year episode and more
importantly thanks to you guys you know
listening for a year straight yeah
sweater if you're a patreon contributor
as well yeah that's Hugh no huge we
honestly our lives are definitely a lot
different we're getting to do a lot more
creative [ __ ] than I think we would have
planned yeah we [ __ ] we we it's cool
man we went on a [ __ ] tour because of
this and now we're about to go on
another one yeah and we I don't think we
would have I don't think we really would
have pressed forward with our mixtape
yeah cause like it was on the podcast
where we talked about it yeah you know
and I think was it your episode I think
I think sanely chill or something so
basically we talked about it and you
know you were like yeah we should make a
mixtape yeah so because the podcast is
going forward you know I think we made
it like one of our early goals that we
would yeah
finish the mixtape and now we're [ __ ]
here into this big
we're gonna drop another project and
yeah didn't just want to say thank you
to everybody yeah one year get ready for
another smoking-hot euros are smoking
hot you're gonna steaming hot content
can't wait to see you all on tour and
yeah we'll see you all next week another
episode Gang Gang Gang thanks bye yeah
thank you Fox new song yeah yeah you
listen to this next week it's out rights
on Monday yeah come on yeah Monday
banger ID spot I go listen bang that
[ __ ] bang that shame that [ __ ] oh yeah I
let the foot in rhythm consume your body
yeah baby it's enough